oh there it is
up there it is
up there it is let's go
big street podcast baby off the rails
you know what to do oh there it is
we got queen here it is
dropping it
[Music]
oh now we're going now we're going now
we're going
h3
[Music]
oh there it is
[Music]
neighbors are going to call an ambulance
if
[Music]
yeah if you guys hear this track
just know it's the hottest
exclusive remix there it is ela climb
2021 top in the charts billboard number
one
[Music]
we're coming for you taylor swift
there's a new female lead
come before your throne you'll climb
it is what it is
off the rails you're [ __ ] out of
breath dude well okay let's just be
honest that's the second time we did it
oh you're giving away the game you're
giving away the game well
i have to explain why i'm so out of
breath i mean i i'm not in good shape
don't get me wrong but
i'm particularly out of breath because
we did that twice because the first time
there was no audio
we missed the mark on that one we may be
over compensating a little bit the
second time
[Laughter]
that was our best intro ever we had to
step it up do you think that government
was better
you know the first one he was just the
first one was better
well we'll never know we'll never know
welcome to off the rails people
love to have you here
energy levels are high clearly
today we're sponsored by me undies and
upstart and i want to give a quick shout
out
to the queen bee
the one and only
no no no no hit me with that whoop there
it is
this is evil klein
the hotly
anticipated looney tunes x teddy fresh
drop is finally here
this thursday at 10 a.m zach you want to
model off your jacket
oh there it is the tf looney tunes
letterman jacket there it is
show the back oh there it is boom how
does it feel how does it fit
oh there it is
the fit of it is amazing it is so high
quality it is
it's probably my favorite jacket i own
thank you bro it is amazing thank you so
much
i'm wearing the bad boy's teeth
oh there it is we redesigned the uh
looney tunes characters to be wearing
teddy fresh we got the beanie
but the whole collection's fire
fresh.com
there it is this thursday 10 a.m there
it is uh get you or your loved ones
something beautiful just in time for the
holidays guys
you can kill them it is you can kill the
music thank you
you don't want to play a good thing out
too much
also just a little reminder black friday
sales going on
you got hot deals like three panel
hoodies still 50 off you got small
medium large sizes still wow just in
time for the holiday holy [ __ ] you know
the color block hoodie is on sale it's
like 15 off it's not
crazy but we never put it on sale so
this is your chance to get it discounted
unbelievable yep and uh spongebob 50 off
again small medium large you got good
sizes
it's all happening
on teddyfresh.com support your queens
people
and uh be there on thursday 10 am thank
you happy holidays
[Applause]
well welcome to the show
we got a great one here
um
lots of stuff to get to
for example um
this apparently
has been trending
is that i laugh like a koala wow
i don't dispute it i guess i just i
don't well here i'll let you guys watch
yeah i hear it i guess
i don't know sometimes i i don't laugh
that frequently you know hard but when i
do i
it's like i can't breathe i'm like
gasping for air so
i guess it sounds like a koala
which is nice i don't i don't mind being
compared to koalas those are adorable
yeah
horrible creatures
and the koala like me
you know lovable but couldn't possibly
exist without the collective support of
the entire world
to make them live they're so
dysfunctional as an animal they
literally eat one niche leaf
eucalyptus
which is already like a toxic
indigestible plant as it is
and these animals should be extinct but
they're not because people love them is
that a good analogy for me maybe i'm not
that lovable
uh you are very lovable i'm just fact
checking all those qual effects not that
i don't fact-check me [ __ ] yo he is
spitting koala fast fact check me i know
what the [ __ ] go ahead factory wait a
whole team back here
i'm just telling you to do it i
qualified a variety of eucalypt leaves
and few other related tree species
that sounds pretty good yeah i mean you
were you were mostly there and tell me
and eucalyptus toxic hard to digest i
believe eucalyptus is toxic to humans
clearly not to koalas
i mean that would be really bad
come on guys
question me on question me on things but
not my koala facts
how's everyone doing
good hanging in
lovely looking at adorable pictures of
koalas right now i just can't stop
looking myself in the mirror in this
jacket it's just [ __ ] dope you do
look good in it thank you
it's just it's thank you thank you thank
you you're very welcome abe you want to
show off your shirt you always look
better than me
uh it's the same shirt that's arguable
but
yeah love it
you know i like the shirt and i didn't
even realize that they're wearing teddy
fresh until you just said it now i like
it a lot more that's a pretty badass
yeah i'm surprised they let us do that
because usually they don't let us [ __ ]
with the ip
right my the bad girls one is even doper
though because you got taz all with the
fat lips looking like sexy as hell
looking like a snack yeah
tasmanians try to get the graphics uh
yeah can you message uh
someone from marketing or lena to grab
us some assets we can show yeah send us
like 700 photos please
yeah like yeah at least that's what they
did last time
thank you guys um
my rash is pretty much gone
yeah you look better i mean i'm still a
little blocky but lots of progress
i was hitting the benadryl hard boy
i was in like a twilight zone oh yeah
i'm surprised they sell that [ __ ] over
the counter because
it's sleepy and horny people must abuse
that right
uh yes yes
which we should tell our audience do do
not
do that don't abuse don't abuse
when you can abuse anything
people get [ __ ] up on cough syrup when
people know not to do that well i gotta
[ __ ] hold their hand and everything
yes don't overdose on benadryl
you know that's a serious message this
is a message with peace and love
still itchy though
but
getting better
not as blotchy as this guy still even
with the rash on my face true
ryan cavanagh
well let's just get right into it um
collected some great memes here
okay this is this one's kind of hard to
explain it's kind of a deep cut
but this thing was [ __ ] can i play
this music even because it's kind of
hard without it oh
we can get a taste
so this guy what he does here i'll just
mute it at this point
you can just mute it yeah
so what this guy does it's really
interesting
he uploads like a hundred tick tocks a
day
doing the same dance to a meme
and that's his content
sometimes it hits sometimes it doesn't
but this one just seems like okay here's
this dude
hiro love him
uh aidsaz hassan a 15-year-old pakistani
schoolboy sacrificed his life while
preventing a suicide bomber from
entering a school of 2000 students
my father said his father said my son
made his mother cry but save hundreds
of mothers from crying for their
children um a very serious message and a
wow what a guy right
what does this tell you
what is he doing
he's singing
he's just oh my god thank you bro
i just want to say thank you
why is he so good at dancing though the
thing is he
he does the same move on every video so
it's not like just that one move it's
not like oh this is my sad one
it's 19.8 million followers this guy
yeah but a lot of them don't hit i mean
like here's one with
because he uploads so much
yeah that video is from like three days
ago
as of the recording of this episode
and he's posted
quite literally like over 100 tick tocks
since then yeah so this one's from 17
hours ago to almost 5 000 likes and
again it's just a meme and him dancing
yeah
it's so [ __ ] weird bro but most of
them
are memes that are somewhat
light-hearted that one really stood out
because it's just this horribly sad
story
so like six million jews were killed in
the holocaust
not only jews but communists homosexuals
and gypsies all perished
in the chambers
and it's a sexual dance
[Laughter]
i guess you to teach the kids however
you can
yeah he's getting the word out i guess
on the morning of 9 11
two planes
hit the world trade center
people were jumping out the building
[Music]
on fire
perishing
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's awesome
yeah why not let's let this guy educate
our youth [ __ ] it they need to see a
cool dude doing the robot and [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know damn let's let's teach these
kids something
please here here's one that's
educational
it's uh in spanish porque
somos saras sila si civalezados
hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah you guys
yeah i just thought this was interesting
account
i guess it's popular among he's a
spanish speaker so if you guys are
spanish speakers you've probably seen
him
bro
we got a little thirst trap
damn dude wow so committed though
interesting guy huh
he is
he's a legend oh i saw one where he
wrote let's not shout him out because
he'll probably be canceled yeah he's
probably a pedo or something he's like
you don't know about that guy he's like
a prolific predator
i can't believe he shouted him out
i saw him reacting to really bad fan art
that was funny and he was like crying oh
here it is
he starts like crying oh
i mean it's nice that people draw you i
mean but
he starts like crying and i mean when
you think about that he makes a hundred
of these a day
you know that he's not crying
wow
he took his breath away look at that
oh he's doing the song by the way of
course
hey hey
i i mean it's just you know it's
flattering but
with peace and love
it's
okay
here's another weird ass video we saw
jeff bezos uh
jeff bezos he's doing some kind of weird
um
propaganda
this was trending you said dan you found
this one this is on youtube's trending
page i was scrolling through it looking
for some some juice for the show and
saw the thumbnails like oh interesting
and so i had a lot of views and um
this is this isn't a direct attack on
ian jeff pays bezos bans power points at
amazon i mean
[Laughter]
here let's watch this but this was
trending for literally no reason has 1.8
million views and look at all this good
pr for daddy bezos let's read the
comments
okay top comment is it seems like a
nightmare to work under jeff right i was
gonna point out a lot of the uh
comments seem to be quite negative about
it but the like ratio is good
overwhelming yeah
so
i don't know i didn't find that this
video really made him come across very
well which is in you know was clearly
the goal here
oh yeah it's definitely a puff feeling
use the tactics of a warlord to
discipline amazon
i mean i don't even know that it's true
like who are you and how do you know
this right but anyway here it is
jeff bezos used the tactics of a warlord
to discipline amazon executives one
morning bezos walked into a critical
meeting with the senior executives to
his dismay however there had been tvs
installed on the walls of the conference
room and it was safe to say that bezos
was outraged about this the reason for
it bezos had never allowed powerpoint
presentations at amazon he believes them
to be the laziest way to communicate
information and instead as executives
write concise six-page essays called
narratives bezos ordered the tvs to be
removed instantly but left the tv
bracket mounts on the wall for years to
come just like an ancient warlord who
collects the heads of his enemies basis
wanted his executives to be reminded of
their mistake every day so next time you
have a big presentation remember that
that's bad that's horrible advice
actually i feel like
he left the brackets on like a head on a
pike as a reminder to his enemy
actually i feel like there's no way this
story's true
there's no [ __ ] way you don't have a
tv in a conference room even if you hate
powerpoints because you've got what are
they supposed to write excel sheets and
spreadsheets and [ __ ] i mean pie charts
there's there are things you need a
television for
that aren't [ __ ] uh powerpoints and
he'd rather read
multiple six-page essays i feel like
this dude just made this up well uh from
what i under the powerpoint thing is
true
um that element of it of him not you
know liking powerpoints but as far as um
you know
driving his enemies from the lands and
hearing the lamentations of the women
and all of the other warlord [ __ ] uh
seems like a stretch yeah i mean i
understand not liking power points uh
but
but
also what's wrong with powerpoints i
think jeff you got a [ __ ] weird
problem dude has he seen ian's
powerpoint yeah not really not all
powerpoints are lazy maybe your
executives just need to step their [ __ ]
up and take a course in powerpoint
production right
slater style i've seen some amazing
powerpoints in my time
do you have anything you want to say to
that ian i mean that's like a draft
attack on you i mean i
it's google slides okay
i'd hope
oh that's true ian uses google slides oh
you don't [ __ ] with powerpoint oh
wait you said that
well he didn't directly confirm it but
um
i'm just asking a question
anyway that was i i don't know why that
was trending but shout outs to
our corporate overlords for uh
the propaganda
i think in the future he should if
somebody tries to bring in a powerpoint
he should um
are you familiar with the concept of uh
decimation that they used to do in
ancient times what does that mean well
they would take one in ten of uh the
troops as punishment and the other nine
would have to kill
the tenth one so i think he should just
kind of
sort of like in game of thrones where
they all like surround and stab jon snow
wow what what what would they have to do
what army would want to kill their own
soldiers well
ones that are doing powerpoint slides
decimation are killing
10th soldier
who did that forgive me if i think it's
the romans it was the romans yeah
forgive me if i'm off here dan but to
certain dominance didn't they uh
forcefully have sex with them too oh
this act
i think that's just in your fantasy
i'm going to read that ain't no fantasy
i i hold on
i'll tell you
decimation was a form of roman
discipline
um the discipline was used every tenth
man in a group was executed by members
of his court the discipline was used by
senior commanders there you go
uh
to punish cowardice
mutiny desertion and insubordination so
these are these are the
these are the the raffians they've
they've lost their will to fight right
they deserve to do we're gonna teach
them yeah let me i'm just looking for
the sodomy part hang on here i swear to
god i heard that it was on an episode of
spartacus or some [ __ ] like yeah so i'm
not saying anything about um
four sexual acts that was the tenth guy
the nine got killed the tenth one he got
laid
forceful
but they were all into men love back
then that was like a thing that everyone
part took in wasn't it i don't know
about everyone but it was more accepted
than in more recent era every everyone
did including you how are we gonna do
without men what are we gonna do without
men oh
jordan they go and fight him on possible
wars
they have sex with each other every
tenth man gets to blow the other one
jordan is always talking about western
civilization and you know arguably that
was the peak of it so it gives you a
little insight rome was the peak of
western civilization
toxic masculinity where have we gone
since then
somebody just probably believes that i
don't know
where where will we be
without men blowing each other
men they're doing impossible things
i've had a man swallow my load like no
woman before
women can't
women can't deep throat me like man can
they take the whole load too and they
ask for more
they work themselves they work him see
works his jaw to death
and women wouldn't do that
i've never met a woman with so much [ __ ]
lust
as some of these guys i meet
where would we be
[Music]
so sad
where would we be without men
huge [ __ ]
just huge all over the place all right
20 of them jordan jordan get a hold of
you they're doing impossible things like
fitting three [ __ ] in their butt this
is the gayest generation in american
history
what how uh uh i do oh you can't find a
woman to fit three [ __ ] in her [ __ ]
what do we do without these amazing men
you got together to celebrate two guys
butt [ __ ]
yeah i mean i guess people get mad when
i make the gay jokes but i'm doing it as
an exact uh
reflection of how homophobic these guys
all
are you know
does that make sense stan
it does
it does so i'm not i'm a father
that's not for me to say
oh great you're not gonna give me a pass
who am i to give you a pass well in your
opinion you can give me a personal pass
i thought it was funny
okay good am i homophobic
it's not for me to say who's to say who
can say god say it dan come on
just say what that he's not homophobic
he's not i i don't think that you're
homophobic thank you
see dance isn't homophobic but that's my
opinion
okay obviously how are you going to give
yourself someone else's opinion well
this is the opinion of jessica at home
watching in virginia it sounded the
question was being
posed in an objective manner as if i'm
the
arbiter thank you for vouching for me
though yeah
what would we do without dan to vouch
for for another man all right jordan
jordan go off king i'd be lost without
another man jordan the question was
about jeff bezos and powerpoint so i i
don't know how we wound up on
where what would we do without power
points with big [ __ ] and them every
time you click to the next screen it's a
bigger [ __ ] mr peterson please try the
first one's a 4-h
i'm going to come respectable but not
not great
or where will we be without the next
slide 5 inches
some say it's perfect dr peterson just
too small dr peterson get a hold of the
next slide six inches pretty normal
standard stuff most people like it
some some men say some men who consider
themselves size queens like them a
little bigger
you go to the next slide you're talking
seven inches that'll be a size king
that's a queen dan
you go the next slide at seven inches
now you're getting into some bigger
territory go off king most people like
it but it's too big for some and not big
enough for the queen's
you're going on to eight
now you're talking [ __ ]
all right you get with this yes yes i
got it like five minutes ago jordan is
the new godfather bear
where would we be oh god cut the music
no
then
you come to me
and you tell me jordan's the new
godfather
how could you talk
so disrespectful to me
there's no godfather
other than me and if you want to talk
about [ __ ] i got a fat one
that's why i get this kind of respect in
the circle
they know i got a fat thick [ __ ]
the jordan peterson with love
and respect
jordan comes to me he says where will we
be without men
i tell him
you would be nowhere without this fat
gunk
damn once you take a ride on the lake
with me
i'll show you a little something about
where will we be without men
[Music]
you want to know something about men
i run this family i tried everything for
you
everything here i know it was you fredo
i know it was you then
you breaking my heart
is anybody left
i'm enjoying it
all right i'm moving on you can come
back now
[Applause]
just give me a minute
one sec
oh wait stand by
he is getting into his
ava
can you hit us with some uh fog smoke
i got you no i had i turned it off
because it was uh drawing too much power
that was what that beeping earlier was
drawing too much power yeah
it's getting too strong compared to your
[ __ ] galactic uh star uh destroyer
you're in right now
i wish it was in a galactic starting
spring
hey trader can you buy me one of those
next sure
sorry all right i saw this on tick tock
last night and i thought this was just
so dirty man
this is the most brutal rejection i ever
seen and
a discount let me just watch it and
we'll talk about it but this guidance
counselor
she should be ashamed okay come on in
hello hi
you [ __ ] [ __ ] tick-tock i swear to
god i i can't do this
i don't know why it always does this you
want to explain to alyssa uh what you
saw or what's going on wait now we
missed
[Music]
like all i'm doing is using the track
pad hello hi
i'm trying to understand why it's
happening this happens
when you scroll up and down when you
scroll right here look
up and down why would that
i think it's when you click on it and
it's full okay
well i need a full screen i'm running a
show here hi
you want to explain to alyssa uh what
you saw or what's going on what i saw
was you stole my heart alley
[ __ ]
would you go to prom with me
[ __ ]
it's a good thing yeah would you
consider it you think about it
but yeah if you'll think about it for
him
give him a yes or no sometime soon
okay come on in
[ __ ] that was the worst worst this kid
is dead he's like gotta move he's gotta
move
he's gotta exchange schools
he needs a new identity
why needs new parents why post that yeah
who posted that the guidance counselor
seems like she's the one that recorded
it oh she should lose her job she should
be banished she should go to guantanamo
straight to guantanamo she should be
decimated she needs to be waterboarded
decimated by her beard she needs to be
designated yeah exactly
yeah i mean like first of all
who would set this up thinking it's a
good idea and i actually do think she
recorded it and put it online imagine
that
i mean was it a matter of if
he talked to the guidance counselor
about how he was oh for secure and she
was like i'll help
yeah this seems like a bad idea like i
don't think this was his idea maybe it's
his mom or something would that be crazy
but you'll think about it
and she's
let's watch it again hello hi
you want to explain so the premise is
obviously
she got called in she thinks she's in
trouble she doesn't know what's going
wrong right this goon walks in she's
probably never even talked to him she
probably don't know who he is
he just got like that weird boys boys
boys crush on her
and she's like what the [ __ ]
uh what you saw or what's going on what
i saw was you stole my heart ally
and then
and then
she realizes
i don't even know this kid
in fact
this kid's been following me home he
makes me very uncomfortable
would you go to prom with me
holy [ __ ] and she looks at the guidance
counselor too like why did you do this
to me
and then you know this kid's poor face
he does this smile but
i know that pain boy
you know that pain it's like there's
nothing it's almost the most painful
thing in life when you're a teenager and
you get rejected like this yeah i think
it's the most painful thing you'll ever
experience in life
you know yeah it's it's rough
what am i reading maybe
[Music]
i'll get to that
i'll get to that ab
oh what
this right here he's like i'm i'm dead
my life is over
his life is over
here let's go back because this is every
this moment tells the whole story
he says well my life's over so i'm
[ __ ] dead yeah would you
consider it you think about it
but yeah if you'll think about it for
him
give him a yes or no sometime soon all
right okay come on in
damn
so
crazy oh
boy
that hug at the end yep
was that the counselor's idea to hug
wait hang on
no think about it
but yeah if you'll think about it for
him
give him a yes or no
this is the villain story begins
this guy's got to join the army or
something and
move to japan or some [ __ ] yeah join a
there's an army in a different he needs
to join the foreign legion
he used to join the space force
exactly as far as what's possible ethan
have you ever had anything happen to you
like this
like oh rejection rejection after like a
prom or a homecoming
let me think here
i've been like i'm usu i i i guess i was
maybe let me think here i've been
rejected yeah i've been brutally
rejected for sure yeah
in high school
not that much
i think i was
i was lucky in high school to date the
girls that i liked
but in college i took some shots
for sure
i liked i liked being bold you know i
like these bold moves where like there's
a girl and that were at the food hall
that i always see that i thought was
like cute and interesting looking
and i would just like work up the
courage and i was like i'm going to be
that guy
so i go i just go and sit with her one
day i says hi i'm ethan i think you're
beautiful and i'd like to get to know
you
and i did that one time this girl i
thought like i thought for sure there
was a
chemistry i felt like this like this is
gonna work
and she says
she's just like oh hi thanks i have a
boyfriend and then
it just the sale was out and now i just
i was like okay and i just bailed
all right see it's just awful that was
painful just because like
you realize all right the way i just
fled with my tail between my legs was
just like so uh
i don't know that
i mean i'm sure that felt bad yeah but
but
you know that i mean
the grand scheme of things that's not
too bad of a rejection i would say let
me think if there's been a worse
rejection than that i have i have one if
i
can share
oh you know we want to hear it so uh
11th grade i asked the girl to it was
prom
and it was in our school's courtyard and
i played on the guitar baby i love your
way by peter frampton
oh so it was it was baldy it was ballsy
oh baby i love your way i was little
[ __ ] romeo you know and i had a whole
thing of roses and
you know the girl and i i thought we
were friends you know i didn't you know
i thought hey you know we go with me to
this dance and
she said no
publicly
and it [ __ ] stung well hold on what
do you mean publicly like where did this
happen in our courtyard and people it
sounds like he made a you made a whole
scene okay wait
let me break this down you're in the
courtyard and high school yes a public
setting yeah see that's that's you're
asking for it bro that's like the dude
who proposes at during halftime at
staples center that's that's a little
much but the crypto.com center actually
yeah i'm sorry forgive me
i i just said [ __ ] it i wanted to go big
and so tell me okay okay so this is
interesting to me so you you have an
electric guitar or a hose acoustic oh so
you got acoustic guitar and then you
have flowers tell me about the whole
setup yeah i i had just
basically got down on a knee
tell me about everything though tell me
about what's there so i see her when you
got down on your knee so yeah i'm like
hey can i share something with you no
hold on hold on hold on you're getting
ahead you're getting ahead
tell me about the setup you said you had
flowers and stuff it was just a bouquet
paint the scene for me okay we're in the
courtyard courtyard it was kind of an
overcast day it was during lunch how
many people are around you [ __ ]
200 hundreds yeah 200 people and and
like how big is the courtyard people are
close by right they're not oh yeah yeah
okay so everybody's kind of watching
what's happening oh yeah and um okay so
you have a guitar and a bouquet with you
yes and what kind of flowers did you get
there were roses red roses yeah there
were roses okay and then so how did you
beckon her to come
to the courtyard she was walking towards
me
and i'm like to my friend wes i'm like
all right i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do
this
and i'm like hey
so-and-so can i talk to you and you have
were empty-handed when you said that no
i had the guitar in my hand you had the
guitar and flowers in your hand yes and
you said can i talk to you can i talk to
you and then i
proceed to get down on one knee and
start strumming the tune okay so it
wasn't you didn't pull her to the center
of the courtyard you just happened to
intercept her there correct
okay and then so you got down on one
knee you start playing ooh baby i love
your weight when did you give her the
flowers
uh after the song and when i said hey
will you go to the dance with me okay
and uh so how did you react
straight up uh no i'm going with someone
else damn let's go that's [ __ ] brutal
yeah i was [ __ ] up and then what
happened after that did she walk away
did you she walked away everyone laughed
at me it was [ __ ] oh
shh
except for my friend who's like consoled
me it made me cry to be honest
when did you cry there or later i walked
away and started tearing up
that sounds dramatic how much of the
song did you play i was
gonna ask the same question because i
just looked it up it is a five and a
half minute long song did how many
verses how did you get three i played a
verse and doubled the chorus and that
was it so like there's a couple minutes
of good playing there
yeah and do you remember do you recall
the look on her face as you played
it was just kind of like what the [ __ ]
is going on were you worried as you were
playing the song like this is not going
good
oh for sure you can you can get a vibe
but you you were committed you were
gonna keep playing yeah [ __ ] it i it was
ballsy and i looked back on it and was
like oh my god that was so embarrassing
but i mean i think it took balls for a
kid junior in high school to do some
[ __ ] like now let me let me ask you is
this like a popular girl that all the
guys wanted
not really
okay that would have made it more cringe
yeah
not really
i thought we were friends we would talk
and you know i thought there might have
been something there but [ __ ] [ __ ] no
dude cam's asking was it kylie jenner no
yeah i know i had to say that
it was not kylie jenner well you know
what zach that's a sweet thing you took
a shot you put yourself out there and
god bless you thank you thank you i
appreciate that sounds brutal though oh
it was hard did people goof on you at
all for it afterwards uh there was like
maybe a week or two of like just like
laughing and like you got rejected
yeah well [ __ ] are too they're too
coward to even take a shot [ __ ] right
i'm like who are you going with i'm like
i'm not going with anyone but who are
you going with exactly you got balls did
you end up getting another date did you
go junior year no stayed uh stayed home
that year well i bet that girl regrets
it now so yeah another year the world
famous zach the sound lad true the mayo
king wearing this [ __ ] and teddy fresh
jacket absolutely
that's a great story
thank you
how long did you cry for like a good
long cry or like a small just a few
tears it was like an embarrassing
probably five minute of like what the
[ __ ] did i just do but my friend
consoled me and he's like bro you gave
her your all what a good guy that's a
good friend yeah he's still my best
friend so shout out what a guy
you want to say his name so we can check
him out wes
i love you if you're watching this nice
guy wes you're a good dude wes is the
man it's rare for friends to be that uh
empathetic i think at that age
especially men yeah
what are we gonna do without them what
are we gonna do without empathetic men
god have you ever seen his [ __ ] sack
do you know how long it is
actually yeah i have seen his [ __ ]
somehow i knew you were going to say
that yeah
i didn't want you to answer to that
actually i mean you're drunk and you go
piss on a bathroom i mean we've pissed
in some horrible places but
yeah
just throw that out there okay do you
want me to continue my line of
questioning down this no if you please
don't
anyone else got rejection stories since
we're on the topic
mine well this sort of reminded me of a
story i had i asked it's a little bit
different but i asked this girl to dance
in middle school
and she said yes and then we went to the
dance and i was too shy to talk to her
the whole [ __ ] yeah that was a
[ __ ] nightmare yeah
actually i just i did have in middle
school i don't i didn't even like write
that off because it's so cringe but i
had the same thing there was a girl i
liked
and then we were like oh we both like
each other
and then
we would like it was
i would go to her
at lunch
not say anything and hold her hand
we didn't talk
and then one of my friends would be
there and i would talk to him and she
would talk to her friend and we would
just hold hands and then leave
without talking to each other that is
i'm sorry go ahead dan well that just
kind of reminded me i dated a girl dated
a girl in middle school in sort of a
similar situation our thing though was
that we like
barely ever talked at school but um
would pretty much exclusively our
relationship existed on aol instant
messenger oh yeah we would talk a ton on
there but then at school it's not like
we like avoided each other or anything
but like
it was like just super awkward and like
you were just describing like at lunch
time she would just be talking to her
friends and i would just be talking to
my friends and like didn't really
interact at all
this is in like seventh grade or
something so dude you are guys are
unlocking memories same [ __ ] with me
dude i am awesome yes
we never talked me this one girl i was
saying we never talked we would
we didn't i didn't know how to kiss for
whatever reason she made out with me
because she made out before i guess but
we would only go to the movies make out
that was it
never talked nothing it's so [ __ ]
weird to think back of it yeah like a
year
actually that's right the first girl i
ever kissed uh was a similar thing that
was pretty much the extent of our
relationship was
going
behind the classroom after school and
making out for like 10 minutes and then
just being like all right bye
that's so weird
those are relationships just so weird
yep
uh olivia you rejected someone from prom
that's pretty epic
i did also hi oh yeah we should probably
explain what's going on she's in
quarantine
i'm
i have a little bit of a cold so far
i've tested negative twice and i'm gonna
keep testing how are you feeling
i feel fine i just have like obvious
physical symptoms of a cold okay she's
stuffed yeah i mean i mean it happens
you know it's the uh kofi's not the only
illness out there olivia
olivia
i've been listening to olivia the entire
time
wow donald is tuned in eh
whoa he's been listening to you
the entire time wait can i ask you are
those teddy fresh necklace
yeah i asked lina
because i love them
yeah it looks great
thank you
all right let's hear how what it's like
to be on the other side of the equation
not getting rejected okay
so
it was like a week before prom and there
was someone who was planning on asking
me and they'd set it up with my friends
and so i knew that that was happening
and that was my plan for prom
but then one day during lunch before
he had prom posed to me i went and i sat
down with this kid who
was like kind of weird and he didn't
have a lot of friends and we just
had a very normal conversation but i
could tell
that he was like getting ready and like
working him himself up to something and
i think he had decided at lunch that he
was gonna ask me and he was like so
olivia like will you go to prom with me
and i like i felt so badly obviously if
i didn't have plans i would have just
said yes i don't really care
but i i didn't know him really at all
but i had this set plan so it sounded i
think he
thought that it sounded like i was lying
and that made me so well he did
so i said no i'm so sorry like my
friends have this plan set up already
and then i wasn't promposed to that day
and that night the boy sent me a bunch
of like angry text messages oh [ __ ] you
got red pills
you blackpilled a guy yeah see that that
that yeah i never took it that far you
just deal with it i mean
blaming the girl some black pill [ __ ]
that's he's too young to be black-pilled
it wasn't like you suck you're a [ __ ]
it was more like hi i have a question
why would you why wouldn't you just say
no if you didn't want to go with me and
i was like no i promise like i have
something lined up but i really it it
was not that and he just
that's the problem
the problem with these guys is that
like i predicted in the in the print the
guidance counselor's office he doesn't
know that girl
he's probably never talked to her
yeah i empathize so much with her in
that video
so how does it feel to be does it it's
got to feel good at least to be like
desirable and to say no
horrible oh come on it feels amazing
horrible i mean there's a part of you
that's like
hey yes
but
but that happens way later right that's
when you're telling your friends about
it and your the emotions are less
crazy
because you just feel horrible
would we be without men
they're doing impossible things they're
asking girls to go to the prom
women are being propped up
by men anybody else got story because
we're way over for break we got to go to
break
it's crickets
let's say let's just thank our sponsors
exciting times thank you guys
not everyone at once here
last call
hey guys i'm so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break okay dan
well guys the holidays are upon us and
it's time to lean in we're talking about
hugs
we're talking secret family recipes
we're talking about seeing the looks on
your loved ones faces as they unwrap
their matching pj sets at the same time
this year meundies wants to help you
bring comfort home for the holidays this
is your sign to surround your family and
friends with comfort
while you're at it why not get a little
something for yourself too
you know
me undies
shout out from the rooftops
change the underwear game for me
i just have [ __ ] underwear my whole life
i think most people just have [ __ ]
underwear you go to
you know a shopping mall you buy what's
there it's [ __ ]
you don't know what good underwear does
for you until you go pick up me undies
soft breathable
beautiful patterns
made by the sustainable micro modal
fabric they figured out there
in the laboratory
it's unbelievable the underwear changed
the game
that's what i live by
they've got new classic plaid and
holiday sweater prints mandy's is
turning up
the comfort this holiday season their
underwear loungewear and sleepwear are
made of soft breathable stretchy fabric
they're ideal for getting cozy by the
fire with a cap cop a hot cocoa make the
whole fam smile with matching pj sets or
spoil your partner with plush robes and
slippers whatever you decide
everyone will be rolling into the new
year comfier than before sizes from xs
to 4xl meundies has a little something
for everyone on your list looking for
more inspiration check out their holiday
gift guide for all things cozy and comfy
me undies has a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15 off and free shipping right
to your door
your days of fighting for your life in
the mall parking lot are over
to get 50 off your order free shipping
and 100 satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com h3 that's meundies.com
h3
what would you do if you didn't have
high interest loans or credit card debt
well with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life upstarts the
fascinating way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have use upstart to get one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff date
rather than looking at credit scores
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in minutes and uh loans between one
thousand
to fifty thousand dollars you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after your loan is accepted find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
h3 that's upstart.com h3 don't forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application that's upstart.com
slash h3
welcome back
um ian you had a you had a story i think
you should share it's pretty good one
regarding the
rejection rejecting yeah
i had one that was
uh
rejecting
someone which was out of character
because i was a total [ __ ] doofus
heartbreaker dude not quite no no no no
somebody loved your ass more than i
could say for myself
i was in middle school and
this girl she was very sweet and nice
but it just that wasn't
there
the the thing
but
she didn't ask me out she uh
asked her mom
to call my mom
without talking to me
and then
um
i came home from school one day and my
mom was like
we're going to go to the movies with
this girl and her mom
um tomorrow and you are going
uh what was your name aragon what was
you what was your thought
we were like okay cool movies or were
you like what's why we meeting them i
was not happy you knew did you know
well when she told me yeah i mean i i
didn't anticipate it happening like that
but i was like and she's like we we
gotta go you're being don't be mean
don't be mean oof mom yeah
she's she's sweet my mom's very sweet
and she didn't want to hurt any feelings
and
so we went
and i was like
anxious the whole time because it was
just like two moms hovering
on either side and we were just sitting
there easy so you guys sat next to each
other with the moms on both that's all
yes
that's epic and then the movie was awful
too so i didn't even get that which
movie was it aragon
aragon he had his own movie yeah no no
no not aragorn oh aragorn who's aragon
it was like a it's like about dragons or
something right it's a dragon fantasy
movie it seems like they totally ripped
off aragon aragon now i'm confused whose
name's whose it's is aragom with an e e
r h
they shouldn't have picked that name for
that character well talk to christopher
palone that's right [ __ ] especially
if it's a movie about dragon and fantasy
i mean that's such a lord of the rings
rip how dare
you yeah movie was was rough and then
after
we they were like let's go to the arcade
it was an arcade next door i love that
and i wanted to go home so bad and we
went to the arcade
and i immediately bolted and i hid in
one of those like jurassic park arcade
machine you know with the you closed the
car
you went in solo i went and hit it and
won oh you waited out that's good
and
she after about 20 minutes i sat in
there killing time
there was a big arcade it was really big
she found me and she got in the machine
nice and i bolted out the other curtains
oh no that's very awkward no social
skills oh yeah
i was very good at those cheeks
what you didn't clap those cheeks
sorry
just gonna leave the camera on you for a
little bit there just sit in that bask
in that asking what you just i stand by
what i said
even after finding out there 12
you can still take it back this is it's
not too late since it's not too late to
take it back
okay
but yeah
delete me from this conversation
but yeah very awkward i felt really bad
when i thought about it you know not at
the time because i was a dumb little kid
but
now i'm like that was so [ __ ] rude
well you know we're not good at
processing emotions at that age and
looking back this has unlocked a lot of
memories for me
when i would go on dates with girls even
in high school i was just i was so
[ __ ] nervous and anxious it was just
like crippling it was just
so serious you know
it's it's i wonder i've been married for
so long now
you know i'll never date again but like
i wonder if i were to date at this age
if i would still be so [ __ ] anxious
and worried all the time if it's any
better
or if now that you're more mature
probably yeah probably not so yeah the
rolls-royce might help yeah the
rolls-royce you think that'd do this
time when uh well when sam's mom called
my mom it went way better this time
right i didn't leave the arcade machine
that's sweet you guys did the jurassic
park together yeah
that's nice it's awesome what a
heartwarming uh
i love that
that explains the jungle room
all came full circle
that's interesting it's fun to go down
these these these uh memories it's just
unlocking so many old emotions man
i apologize for saying if you can clap
those cheeks
okay way too late you said i stand by
what i said i didn't i didn't he took it
back let's not hold it against him he
took it back he came around i take it
back
yeah he took it back
well that was fun
um let's move on to our main segment
here
this is pretty interesting i think you
guys are going to like this it's a
little left field segment
we thought you know
the bathroom in our office is very
vanilla
you got
the toilet you got the sink you got the
paper dispenser
and that's it i mean it's a
run-of-the-mill toilet but
we thought you know
what would each of our vision be
for a perfect bathroom extreme makeover
office bathroom edition
all the freaking way to the tee
we all
each
formulated and pitched our perfect
bathroom and what we want to do is show
them all to you
we have lots of options and on friday
we're going to do a fan poll
to vote who's got the best bathroom and
then
i'm going to drop a million dollars to
make it happen no i'm just kidding
because these are all like insane ideas
i don't think we can make it happen
wait you're not committing to
actually building the winner let's see
who wins
i've got a bunch of like five grand
oh that'll get us about
can make that work ten percent of the
way oh mine it will work with some of
them on some okay let's see
within reason i'm actually willing to to
do it
i know my idea is like uh
probably cost a million bucks
to do good
but with that being said if it's too
expensive we can just get like a gold
let's just get a plunger and spray
painted gold and you know that's a
decent start yeah
maybe sharpies gift card
all right well with that being said
let's roll our intro video set it up hi
everybody my name is ethan klein i've
been pooping for 36 years it's almost a
daily basis i would say i'm a serial
pooper that would that would mean you
know i spent a lot of time in the
bathroom
our bathroom is just not up to par and
it breaks my heart i go in there there's
one ply toilet paper finger rips right
through that the last time i got any
play you know was when my toilet when i
ripped through the toilet paper and
accidentally fingered myself you know i
prefer to have a better atmosphere for
someone who takes pooping as seriously
as i do i mean from the day i was born i
pooped every day so you could say i'm
very passionate about it so i'm really
excited you know for this bathroom
remake i think it's about time we kick
it up to the next level
by the way
i i i kind of defamed myself there i
just want to make clear we have nice
toilet paper in this office okay
i'm glad you said something because i
knew someone would call this out because
in that video when the finger went
through that was clearly not single play
no we have nice toilet paper come on i'm
not a [ __ ] tyrant yeah we got that
kirkland two-ply we actually have a
quilted northern three-ply yeah we got
the good [ __ ] we have really good toilet
paper
i may treat my employees like [ __ ] but
they get good toilet paper for sure
that's a consolation we don't treat our
[ __ ] like [ __ ] exactly i treat our [ __ ]
better than i treat our employees
all right so let's go from the top here
let's start well here's our original
bathroom let's take a look
this is what it is now
okay
i mean pretty run of the mill i mean
it's it is spacious i'll say it's large
in there it's it's it's nice normal
spacious
pretty run-of-the-mill you might even
say that that's a downside though
because it's like cavernous in there you
think it's cavernous yeah like a man's
anus
okay
we have a bidet too
i actually used the bidet yesterday oh
[ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
coming around i knew you would well
because i was having like not good not
healthy moments in there you know
without getting too graphic
and it called for but actually it felt
it was nice it was a nice experience it
didn't feel gross like i expected nice
it's a little shocking like when it hits
you at first but it's a good time it's
quite a torrent and i wouldn't say it's
perfectly aimed but it's pretty good
yeah yeah
because it doesn't come right from the
bottom it kind of comes from like the
back yeah you kind of have to like lean
forward you gotta embrace it i just told
zach imagine i'm
under you like without and just gonna
feel good blowing into your ass
by the way i do actually have a
criticism of this toilet and i don't
know if it affects you guys i can't
stand the small toilet seat that's like
a lady toilet seat
and i'm not i'm not like well endowed or
anything but i mean
if i'm sitting my dick is gonna touch
the top tip of that and there's nothing
worse this is this is actually an
elongated toilet seat that's tiny it's
smaller than the bowl
yeah it's it's not as wide but it's
longer i became an expert because this
is not longer you need we need like the
xl big boy dan you agree with me i do
it's too small yeah and again i even i'm
like i have to like maneuver to not it's
just i'll be rubbing up against the
porcelain there when it touches the ball
or the seat it's just it's not a good
time not good so
well anyway here's our bathroom okay
from the top
obviously we have some gripes so
olivia's first let's take a look at her
dream bathroom olivia are you there you
want to kind of narrate this for us
yes i'm here
um okay so here we go
yep so right up the top looking pretty
good how do is there a way i can scroll
through these without i don't want to
like ruin the surprise here but
this is fine all right what are we
looking at
this is the rave room
um it is a silent disco experience so
there's headphones and there's going to
be a dj on top of the bathrooms like on
the ceiling there's a dj that watches
you go to well it'd be outside but like
on the roof of it
yeah
okay so we have like a full-time dj
playing music
um unless someone wants to volunteer i
used to dj
i used to do dj in high school yeah
here's the dj view let's go down here
oh [ __ ] okay the party puper you have
the umots over those i've noticed it's
the party peeper
love it and we're gonna have a bouncer
even as well like a disco thing it could
be damn yeah it looks like yeah
so that's pretty easy it's up to us if
we want to go outside of the
outside of the family on that one
so you're gonna sit you put on
you put on headphones
you have a personal disco
fun
i'm gonna do it
it's a euro vibe yeah yeah
yeah it's a party in the bathroom yeah
the longer i look the more excited is
there is there another one no that's
just these two
fun what kind of music we playing like
edm house music stuff like that depends
on the uh the tone of the day
it could be happy hardcore it could be
uh
maybe it'll be a bunch of slow songs
right and the djs are they take requests
or do they play they're just they
they're professionals they do their own
thing they don't take requests
they take requests after 2 p.m
i just decided okay got it that's that
free freestyle after two is that is that
daft punk that's djing
maybe that's me and you zack and
definitely somebody emulating that yeah
perhaps this one i feel like we could do
you know this one's doable actually i
mean besides hiring a full-time dj it
might be a little expensive but
my biggest dream is to get david guetta
on top of that bathroom
shout out to the families
that would be epic
yeah the cr the christmas miracle david
guetta how about this
when the poop hits the water the base
drops
shout out to the family this one goes up
to george floyd
shout out to his family
oh and i also want the soap to be a
pressed molly pill
like in the shape of it molded so wait
the soap
dispenser no the soap bar like a bar
soap
yeah oh so you can eat the soap and trip
if you want to maybe oh yeah i think the
suggestion was just it looked like that
oh it just looked like a molly pill i
mean it would be that'd be expensive so
let's be honest
i could get a custom soap i mean as long
as it's not actually made of molly
well that's less fun
well that's what i'm saying then let's
eat the soap
have a good night
all right this is impressive i like it
actually pretty doable too i feel like
we could do this for on a modest budget
yeah i think they do like a black light
room
5k i think we could get here with the
with the party pooper
with the lasers
let's mop it up to like 25. i mean i'm
doing it on a budget dan i'm not you
know what i'm saying
we're doing it on a budget here
all right congratulations this is
exciting are you parked do you like the
disco olivia is that something you like
i don't
like not even necessarily but sometimes
going to the bathroom by yourself you're
like you just want to do something
besides be in the bathroom you know yeah
got it it's your break time
i feel that
you deserve you deserve to dance a
little bit
exciting
fun good it's good submission olivia
thank you
the party pooper
[Applause]
alrighty up next is ian's
what have we got from ian his dream
bathroom
oh going a little old school
the old uh this is like the
20 000 leagues under the sea vibe eh
yeah little jules vern
vibes
so you've got
the aquarium uh sort of porthole there
with the live fish in it
and then you've got the periscope
hanging from the ceiling
uh when you look in that you can see the
los angeles skyline connected to the
roof
beautiful and uh
there's a little you can kind of pilot
from your from your throne there with
with the steering wheel and there's a
little tentacle that
pops out the toilet to you know give you
a little bit of a better time if you
like
i like that idea does it let people
clean you or is it yeah it can give you
a little wipe little is it there for a
must a massage or a wipe
a bit of both we'll have settings like
bidet settings
so you could choose a little bit of a
hentai vibe as well a little bit
identical
yeah
just i mean it is kind of it's quite
beautiful
yeah i think it's it's actually like
from a design aesthetic it's kind of
nice
that's what i said
it's fairly
you know it's modest i think we could
achieve this with the budget um well
yeah this one's a little more expensive
with all the metal and [ __ ]
are those doubloons uh real
yeah we'll have to factor that in okay
because that could run you up which one
the doubloons on the right that are on
the treasure oh the bullions yeah
the balloons the zip the balloon
the balloons okay the gold coins thank
you dad
nerd
you're not into
pirate stuff
what do you call them balloons no
doubloon doubloons gold doubloons how
about these nuts
that didn't really work
um i thought they were called bullion
like gold bullion well that's a more
generic i believe doubloons were like uh
spanish coins during the uh
age of uh exploration
wow
your knowledge is uh
you learned something it was exhaustive
nobody else is like that and every
pirate thing ever it's like i'm wearing
my gold i don't know i've been watching
i've already watched 60 episodes of one
piece and i've never heard anyone
reference uh the bullion or the balloons
hmm i've heard surrender yeah booty
that's it i've heard of the blinds
though thank you thank you
you guys were holding no i i'm ignorant
i shouldn't but gold coins we're talking
about yeah thank you got it got it
thank you thank you we're going down so
this looks a little pricey thank you
love love says two doubloon coins are
worth approximately four dollars wait
those have those have a current value
yeah apparently it's so aren't they
solid gold how are they only worth four
bucks yeah that seems i don't know maybe
are you sure it wasn't four dollars like
in the 1600s yeah that would be a lot
back then
it's 22 karat gold i don't know what
that's 400 today sign me up bro
those are 200 that sounds that sounds
good yeah 400 today
that's a bit more yeah that's kind of
dope did i miss the days when you could
just cruise with the gold coin
it's like good cheddar
just flick it at someone when you want
to want to buy something
sick should start
being one of those
gold apocalypse guys yeah nothing says i
can't mint my own gold coins and what
carry them around a little pouch
anyway coming down here this looks
pricey what is this ian so that's the
view from the uh the toilet beautiful
you will have a big projector um so this
is essentially like looking at the front
of the submarine
and we'll have you know a lot of marine
life cruising by
sometimes a giant squid and you the
the ship wheel will help you navigate
wow it's interactive oh very cool yes so
you will be piloting the submarine
uh as you should this is beautiful
honestly
and sometimes if you if you [ __ ]
you might see it float across
once you flush you it kind of you see
the fish going into a feeding frenzy
over your ship you see it float on by
that's very cool yeah
well wouldn't you be leaving how does
that work like physically because you'd
be going away from the poop
well it depends how you steer you know
how it exits the ship is maybe we shoot
it at the front
right that would be interesting shoot it
right in front of that you can use the
[ __ ] actually
as a weapon to blast the giant squid to
uh get it to leave you alone
so it's kind of like like a minigame
that's interesting though yeah i think i
might have [ __ ] my pants okay mike mike
chill and then this is the final view
it's a statue
it does kind of look like me doesn't it
it's i didn't know i didn't notice that
before yeah definitely you i mean
there's oh my god
i was just i just searched beside an
image
wow weird
that's not arcadian oh really you didn't
edit your face on that man i don't know
what happened that's kind of crazy you
didn't edit your face on this
no
trippy interesting that is trippy
anyways though i do want that statue
and uh so yeah
i gotta say
i'd love to [ __ ] in this bathroom
it's beautiful
i'd love man i'd love if some crazy
casino in vegas or somewhere made
something i mean this is this is a real
attraction here
it could be you
it could be it could be this could be
you but you playing
it could be
well i love it ian um great job i
actually would really love to [ __ ] in
this thank you
means a lot
even just something a little more simple
i guess but like if you're at an
aquarium
and you know sometimes under the
aquarium they have these glass
walls facing
the big tank i mean just even having a
bathroom down their face in the tank
would be pretty beautiful
that's easier obviously we just need to
build uh yeah maybe we can compromise
with that yeah
first you need the aquarium
love that here
thank you
thank you all right cameron cameron you
have two parts i'm noticing you have uh
am i just open part one part two
yeah you can uh open part two uh after
the fact let's just look at part one for
now
okay cameron is very nice oh thank you
well i agree i am very fond of cameron
appreciate it
so here is cameron's
kind of getting a trumpian vibe here oh
that's not what i was going for at all
well you're at the top of a tower it's
kind of like a ivory tower gold-plated
tell us about it oh i mean man it's a
corrupt description already uh so i this
is something i popped up
on my tick tock it's an aesthetic called
frasier bane which is based off of uh
the interior design of the television
sitcom uh frasier
and it's just i don't know just the
micro style that popped up a lot in the
90s and early 2000s of
a sophisticated place to [ __ ] as well
that of course is as uh kelsey graham
grammar
falling off stage sure awesome
sure is
well you've got the space needle in the
back so you're in seattle yeah because i
mean that's where frasier part of the
fragrance yeah exactly so and that's a
penthouse that's a beautiful view right
and you know it's it's as you can tell
it's a little more spacious the toilet's
in a different spot so i thought we
could knock down a few walls
and expand out a little bit add a little
library there
sure why not i hope that as you can see
on the right there there's a fresh copy
of the new york times maybe you saw the
crossword puzzle
every day sophisticated yeah and they're
sophisticated if you scroll down a
little bit more in the expansion wait
what the [ __ ] i've been a little bit
homesick so i just wanted to i was
wondering if we could recreate is this
the room leading up to the fraser
building yeah so i was hoping we could
uh recreate my favorite part of boston
and just uh recreate the museum of fine
arts's
rotunda
[Music]
yeah so that's that's my vision for the
perfect sophisticated beautiful [ __ ] and
this is just one man's abode this is
this is wealth beyond the greatest kings
of all time i mean we got the five
percent we can do this yeah that's true
genghis khan would cry at the thought of
a of a toilet this magnificent right
i do feel like it's going to be a little
tough to get this in under 5k though i
see okay so i mean this is where the
part two comes in then i'm willing to
compromise i prepared a budgetary
restriction for part two
yeah my proposal is that we can get rid
of all the fraser stuff and just keep
the regular bathroom oh okay uh at the
top of the emma phase rotunda
is there really a bathroom there yeah
that's our that's our best
it's the current bathroom as is yeah so
that's great because i don't have to do
anything you just have to be in boston
oh no we bring boston to us yeah yeah we
just recreate it all i know a good
marble guy oh perfect yeah
can you work for 5k yeah we'll figure
something yeah we'll figure something
out what we could do is like um
one of these set perspective walls like
a fake wall with a perspective
of this of this setting of this setting
beautiful maybe some steps too just to
sell the perspective can we get one of
those like stair master things so it
feels like you're going up a bunch of
stairs like a little tiny escalator with
five steps yeah
yeah we could do that awesome that
sounds like a lot of work just to go to
the bathroom
dan have you not seen any of these
well just no i'm not the work to get it
overhauled i'm talking about literally
having to go up a stair master yeah i
mean that sounds like a pain
well it's an escalator
oh okay yeah it would be awesome okay
well in that case sure yeah
beautiful what what a sophisticated take
thank you on the bathroom cameron is
doing a fantastic job i think he's a
star
trump is a fan it reminds me of his own
home big fan
cameron's a great guy
up next we have
dan's ooh this is very beautiful
kind of magical a magical moment here
yeah that's that's a little bit of the
vibe i was going for so i mean fantasy
going in a slightly different direction
than some of the ones uh before although
maybe more akin to um
ian since that's sort of an old school
retro science fiction but yeah um
i i just want to be i want to feel like
i'm at peace when i'm in there and i
want to feel one with nature and one
with the universe one with god one with
the um earth the maker
and one with gaia yeah
and one
excellent way of doing that is to just
kind of bring bring all those things
into the bathroom
you know what's funny this one's
actually pretty doable
well wait until you see the other
pictures well because right now i'm
seeing wallpaper some you know
prosthetic kind of
tree tapestry whatever very nice though
beautiful setting maybe if i can maybe
have some speakers that's giving nice
ambient nature sounds yeah i actually
believe i guess let's go to the next one
here right it's probably not so this is
the ground you're looking down
right and so while you're on the toilet
you have like a japanese zen um
uh
seems like a schlep from the john
a schlep
well if you're sitting
okay no it's like a meditative practice
you're sitting there and then you pick
up the um
the scraper thing and you kind of draw
lines
through the sand and then when you're
done
it'll have kind of like a shaking
base that'll sort of like an
etch-a-sketch reset it
because it's all about you know creating
something and then letting it go
making a poop exactly you got it
this is beautiful the sounds are really
set to me
i like it
i'd also if we don't want to do nature
sound i would be okay with just a sine
wave of the god tone that we were
talking about 436 hertz just playing
[Music]
continuously yeah
and yeah just to complete the sort of um
zen vibe of it all uh a koi fish in the
tank
that's nice i don't know if that's
enough space necessarily well they grow
to their environment so you know this
may not be to scale
like a smaller one yeah a small koi
okay
coys are expensive by the way
so that might set us back
that's okay
i'm not i'm not paying you are so that's
okay okay fair enough
oh
don't be cherry blossom uh this is part
of the wallpaper um you know and also uh
the blossoms themselves will have a
projector like a 360 projector with just
continuously following uh
a cherry blossom wow
yep beautiful
this is a magical spiritual
uh moment which i mean this is just me
but that i feel like that's how you
should be feeling while you're taking a
[ __ ] so if i can be honest with you this
is i feel like this is doable to an
extent you know we're trying to keep it
within reason i mean
this is definitely doable we'll just
dump a bunch of sand on the floor
well
the mechanical device that then shakes
the ground like an etch-a-sketch i mean
that might run a little a little hot
that's a challenge definitely we could
just have someone come in after everyone
shits and reset that's probably cheaper
that's probably cheaper to just have
somebody on staff
whose job it is to reset the sale yeah
this reminds me of like a nice like
relaxing kind of like a pirates of the
caribbean you know everybody likes that
ride because it's so nice and relaxing
now now dan if i wanted to [ __ ] on the
sand is that doable it is not cat litter
it's it's regular sand and so it doesn't
work it doesn't clump the way that you
would expect that does pose a problem
though because if people start [ __ ]
and pissing on the sand that's gonna
ruin the vibe
i mean that's a big if i i want to squat
on that sound dude i'm game for that i
knew you would [ __ ] ruin everything
zach
but they're gonna be splashing at least
maybe not [ __ ] but they'll be urine
splashing for sure well we can maybe you
know once once a week once every two
weeks we'll we'll do a full refresh on
the sand
yeah you're gonna need to do that to
keep it fresh
well i love it it's gorgeous thank you
thank you
well done really happy with how it came
out i love honestly i'd love to [ __ ] in
all these bathrooms that seems really
kind of a peaceful lovely moment too
i love the peach blossom or the cherry
blossom projector yep
super nice
thank you thank you no thank you
ab is up next what do we got here oh
what and god's [ __ ]
i can't i consider it costs with mine
okay oh [ __ ] dude
okay now we're talking okay this we have
the budget for okay
so if i may um
it's based off of someone i don't know
if i should say their name no i'm not
going to say their name but it's someone
that i dislike i think a lot of us
dislike he looks familiar the idea and
then
you could [ __ ] in his mouth basically
and then also the only other addition
would be a mirror so that every time you
[ __ ] in his mouth you could see it you
got to watch yourself
yes you take pride in it as you [ __ ]
honestly this is hilarious and doable
cost efficient
okay [ __ ] you know what i am almost
petty enough to want to do this
i knew you'd like it
is this going to get us in tos service
if we make a life-size uh no it's not
anyone specific i mean i kind of base it
off a few people or one yeah it's an
amalgamation it's like they say any any
resemblance to real life figures purely
purely coincidental yeah
um
i don't listen i don't want to be a
hater here we go but
okay you know what that second one
actually addresses my concern i was
going to say the bill of the hat looks
like it would be cutting into your back
but by shrinking the hat um that
actually circumvents we could figure
what am i making and this guy's bald
which is nice because it seems like he
was trying to hide it in the first one
but the second one the hat's too small
you can see he's bald yeah right no yeah
when i was uh asking cam to help me
design this he suggested the smaller hat
which does does seem more efficient but
i care more about realism
i understand your dedication and respect
your dedication to realism um i just
again i i do have some logistical
concerns about option a there this is
great i'm okay with just doing a
painting as well i honestly i'm i'm
ready to green like this let's [ __ ]
go we can have a ryan cavanaugh one
right next we'll have one be ryan
cavanaugh and one this fictional
character
has no resemblance to anyone in real
life my imagination maybe now to flush
it do you like push the hat down is that
the flushing thing
i'm i'm i'm honestly i don't care about
the details i'm not picky i just want to
shake it in this person's mouth yeah
you know we should get two mirrors so we
can see from different angles so if we
pee i'm not that i'm not that keen on
the watching myself poop part you will
be
when you do it here until you're in
there you'll get a kick out of it
honestly dude this is kind of [ __ ]
amazing thank you and ryan kavanagh is
begging for one of these two he's
probably into that kind of thing as well
we have multiple bathrooms wait what
happens if he's into this thing then
it's
is that complicated or is it still good
yeah i don't see that as
a hurdle no it's not hurdle no it's okay
if he has like a scat fetish we don't
judge
that's up to him we're giving him what
he wants yeah in fact you might say this
is a kindness right yeah
wow i'm impressed man
i love it what can i say
i'm ready to greenlight it
i wish i thought of it [ __ ] with brian
cavanaugh
oh
beautiful
zach
yeah zach streamed up for us oh wow
wow who could have seen this one come in
so
this is i call it rock and roll yoker
chic
and joker
joker oh joe rock and roll joker yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so you have joaquin
looking at you
um
you have highlander on a 50-inch uh tv
looping you cannot change it it's only
highlander i didn't know you were such a
highlander fanatic greatest movie ever
made
you like the long hair you like the
bravado yeah i mean it's it's just it's
just a badass movie amazing soundtrack
like you can't beat it
um
i've created a mechanical arm that wipes
your ass for you okay
that is coming down from the ceiling
that looks expensive the other
everything else looks very doable but
the mechanical arm yeah we'll figure it
out and uh then you have uh two rolexes
uh next to you you have a kermit and a
daytona
why two
why not
well i mean but why two like either one
this is making sense bathroom dan but
i'm just trying to they're his favor
yeah they're the ones i want yeah but
okay but there's okay so it's just
because those two particular ones are
the ones that you want yes
because normally i would say either one
or like a whole array of them but twos
oh just seems kind of strange i'm very
content with two okay but are you going
to be able to like put these on and wear
them or they stay in the bathroom uh no
you it's like when you go and taking
[ __ ] you take them off and then like you
can let them sit there it's a whole it's
a whole you admire them while you [ __ ]
right right right right can you take me
your picks with them sure okay why not
and then what's with the john cena um
so uh that was added because it's mao
actually um oh there's a tick tock
that's like my favorite tic toc by the
way i'm sorry to interrupt i just love
how these dudes embrace the balding like
these [ __ ] know how to ball
like no one else they embrace it like no
one else in history did
he's like i'm bald and i'm just owning
this [ __ ] i'm gonna turn my head into a
flying saucer
so that's on there because it's awesome
favorite tik tok there's a tick tock
with that picture going around right now
oh show it to me uh okay i can
he would love to he's been playing it
non-stop torturing me and ian don't hold
out on me maybe i'm gonna send it to you
and then can you
send it in the chat and i'll pull it
i'll go i got you thank you dan wait koi
are only 150 bucks how long it depends
the show quality coins go up to 10 000.
oh well we i mean we'll get a 51 they're
going to die every week this is a show
we need show quality okay well it's
actually cool i mean dan's a koi boy
koi boy that's right
undoubtedly
well let's get a let's let's view this
tick tock to get the full
experience of this bathroom i'm sending
it right now it almost looks like a
green room like before joker went out
and killed the show host right that's
that's the shot yeah got it it's
supposed to intimidate you and kind of
funny enough scare the [ __ ] out of you
um so that's that's really funny that's
what i was going for
i've never seen carpet in a bathroom oh
yes so that's a bad i mean yeah carpet
in the bathroom is pretty rough it keeps
keeps your feet warm i like the ferrari
red it's very specific
there's just lots of wad what the
[Music]
that's it that's it okay put that in
tears every time zach cries until he
laughs every time he sees us one more
time
[Music]
that's it why don't we just create
recreate that that would be in my budget
he showed me that to me like 15 times
yesterday
well we called him out for it we started
here like in the corner we could hear
the sound playing he started watching
the corner by himself i just hear this
in the distance
well they i like that they're they're
taking it serious yeah they're paying
references well why don't we just create
that we can do that because there's so
much there's so much more but that
picture is giving homage to the greatest
tick tock i've ever seen okay well at
least i understand the shrine the toilet
shrine yes so you you probably get on
your knees and pray before you yes to
what was the proper pronunciation dan
barack
john cena no no no but um
in chinese dialect
john cena i know you would say his name
oh do you guys see that video of john
cena apologizing
yo what the [ __ ] wait that video is so
weird what was he apology can you pull
it up now that i've gone there he said
taiwan was a
yeah and china got cucked him so hard
yeah well i mean he wants to remain in
their good graces because he's very
popular there and uh
apparently his fluent mandarin which is
very impressive really because yeah i
saw the apology and
man fluent mandarin i was like what the
[ __ ] like damn he's scared if he's
apologizing like and he is fluent in
china are you serious yep
john cena
he's the real mr worldwide back the [ __ ]
off pitbull what language does he speak
probably spanish yeah so that's good
but mandarin's impressive it is
impressive uh that ain't easy for for
english it is not it is not an easy
language to learn or so here and so
that's why we worship him wait does he
really like could do you fact check that
he speaks i'm looking at it he is fluent
in chinese how did he do that can you
pull up that someone give me that video
what's the backstory there
why did he learn chinese
did he like live there did he learn did
he do like [ __ ] rosetta stone i mean
what's the story here
uh he learned mandarin during his time
in the wwe so that he could help in the
company's quest to break into the
chinese market dude that is insane
levels of dedication from john cena to
learn mandarin he's a he's an impressive
dude
well anyway he said taiwan is part of
china which like you know china's like
imperial psychopaths
they want to take uh
yeah they want to take taiwan which is
like i guess an autonomous country but
china says no you're part of us
and he's uh you should note that the us
government also does not recognize
taiwan as an autonomous well u.s
government could suck these
they don't
i really want to get into it but it's a
very complicated history the the
situation with taiwan
taiwan also uh believes that they are
china i don't know if you know that but
they
that's a hard sell
they're like no no no you're part of us
correct i mean that that is their
official position so
well um
so what did he he just said taiwan is a
country and then yeah that's a big no-no
in in china okay so here he is groveling
it's awesome
oh he um just a line in a movie
no he was doing a press circuit yeah oh
you're [ __ ] up john you're going to
find yourself in a shallow grave next
time you go to china
[Music]
i thought he just rehearsed this because
he was like oh my god this is i just
love this no no no no no
chinese
by the people's republic of china so
hard
this is crazy propaganda right like i
imagine this being like i am so sorry
for saying that native americans were
first in america
uh we all know that that's just
propaganda the the americans were here
first and just took the took the or like
even now with like little critical race
they're like i'm so sorry for saying
that there was slavery in america we all
know that was just propaganda like he's
he's shielding crazy chinese propaganda
right now
was so so so important i love and
respect china and chinese people
he's on the verge of tears i love and
respect china and chinese people
i'm so sorry
oh he was due to
lose a lot of money
oh yeah he's like [ __ ] taiwan i
got like 50 million dollars on the line
here or more
that's awesome
don't worry guys he's just farming
social credit score
alternate title john cena
avoids execution
this is a better apology than travis
scott's that's true
when it comes to apologizing to uh
winnie the pooh you you better be
serious
i said taiwan was a country but then i
realized i was really i really really
really like money sorry
it's awesome
there's a second one here he's i know
this is a tantrum but it's just so
fascinating that he speaks mandarin
isn't it
here he is speaking
oh yeah
yo the chinese must be so tripped the
[ __ ] out by this
i'd love to talk to a chinese person's
reaction to this
oh sorry
[ __ ] taiwan i want to say now before you
[ __ ] taiwan
so i just looked it up invade taiwan
there are only 15 countries in the world
that recognize taiwan as a country um
almost all of which are in central
america or the small caribbean islands
yeah it's just politics though because
china would be we'll just be like
well if you recognize taiwan like they
do the same thing about tibet who
recognizes tibet
uh
yeah uh very few if any countries
recognize tibet as an independent
country yes so
they trying to be like okay you
recognize taiwan then we basically shut
off the valve
bye bye
bye bye okay anyway back to this i just
got
such a tangent there john cena what do
we got here zach okay so uh behind you
have a original nagel uh painting
which is a lot of money and a you'll
notice a full meat buffet
all meats all meats you want to walk me
through this what kind of meats are we
looking at you got your you know your
standard bacon uh sausage
beef patties maybe a little kebab some
shawarma
yes
i'm not an expert but i'm going to go
out on a limb and say that raw meat in
close proximity to a toilet is probably
a health code violation it's not wrong
i wouldn't be able to eat that meat so
you notice that's a no for me dog the
pit fire under it that's what's heating
and cooking it but dan does have a point
because when you flush they they do they
know that [ __ ] particles yeah all over
the place i feel like this is a
you're gonna get e coli from from this
bathroom can you get e coli from eating
poop
yeah
no okay not meat though because we're
cooking that e coli right off so you're
saying as long as the meat is maintained
at a good temperature the [ __ ] particles
that land on it won't harm you yes you
can eat them safely and you can tell
that the temperature will be um well
maintained and exact with that very
professional looking uh
small uh a small gas fire it looks like
yeah at home depot's finest um is there
enough ventilation yeah this seems like
a hazard bro no no no it's all good you
know
i'm just a little concerned it's all
good it's like carbon monoxide poisoning
and other types do you get a little
tasting plate before you poop or after
or what's the method whatever you want
before after during um i'm a fur
believer and you know you can you can
cheat while you eat
so um sheet while you eat i agree i mean
i done it yeah it's it's it's a vibe
dude catch a vibe
you know you got that 80s painting um
and yeah again you got that referral
open flame really close to that original
uh piece of art there nah it's protected
it's fine there's more
um and so the other side is a stack of
jcm800 marshalls with a 58 a 59 les paul
all original and eddie van halen's
frankenstein guitar
this is quite a bathroom i gotta say
yeah
this is the closest to like a
i don't know what to say but this
definitely
says zach it's very exact energy it's a
very
much all over the place i can't really
point to a unified theme to tell you the
truth because it's rock and roll it's
joker brain baby yeah it's it doesn't
have to be or no judgment i like it you
know it's very zach it's it's very zach
when we were going over these everyone
was kind of like i'm not sure i'm not
sure zach was like red ferrari red shag
wrote a pile of meat he knew every
single piece
right on top of his head he's been
thinking about that's awesome i've
thought about it
he's a man that knows what he wants and
what he wants is whatever this is
it's love baby
yeah but yeah well the passion's there
clearly thank you thank you i do
appreciate that
love that
i'm the meat chef
that's right and you can be in my
bathroom
love all the way from sweden
yes sir is bringing us
some cool
rustic bathroom looks here we've got the
lincoln logs as they call them here in
america go ahead oh yeah so
you know i figured when i come to
america i'd want my like swedish safe
place
where you know i can relax and kick back
so and also spread the swedish swedish
culture to america so that's what i've
done here
so where's this
appears to be a photograph of ben
stiller who i believe is in america
that's just i thought it's about ikea
that's a mirror i thought that's just a
mirror oh wow the whole cabin vibe you
know it's very swedish you'll see more
of the bathroom right there will be more
swedish hints this is like some viking
memorabilia yeah yeah yeah
very swedish that's very sweet what is
this what's this what's the swedish
regard for like their viking heritage
do you guys like proud of it how do you
learn about vikings in sweden i mean
there's like the cool
viking like cartoonish cool stuff
until you realize that they're actually
like crazy and did a bunch of bad stuff
yeah the vikings were brutal
yeah but if you look up like don't if
you ignore that part they're kind of
cool right yeah you guys learn all about
like viking conquests and stuff and and
yeah history interesting
yeah they're psychotic weren't they they
like trip drugs and just kill people and
rape everyone sure sure
sure
moving on
oh interesting wow homage to the greats
the swedish greats i'm assuming this is
our one
that's the king of sweden yeah
the 16th
you know he's like
one of uh sweden's biggest ki or
like biggest icons
and yeah everyone in sweden loves him
everyone everyone are you saying that
ironically or truly
um
ironically i guess
he seems like a goofball though these
edges
yeah those are red it's like a meme in
sweden where people edit
like hats and stuff on this on him um
but you know it's not like
like english weird royal where they do
like fly to a bunch of islands and stuff
it's just kind of goofy and weird he's
like here i am but he he has like a
lineage to like
old royalty
oh yeah a bunch of incest and stuff like
that yeah nice
very cool
he has no power he's just a figurehead
right i'm assuming no yeah i mean many
people like complain about him getting
tax money but i mean he
there's a lot of gossip and stuff like
that he generates a bunch of jobs so i
think it kind of equals out in my
opinion
is does he [ __ ] like crazy
surely yeah is he married
yeah yeah yeah of course love forgive me
just take it back like a second did you
say incest or ancestry
definitely incest okay yeah i mean all
all royals in europe are incest very
much and yeah this dude is french i
think would you be willing to swap him
out for pewdiepie maybe
um yeah sure
well i mean they they can coexist i
think yeah okay wait what do you mean
swap them out for pewdiepie
pewdiepie in the photos because it's
someone i understand from sweden all
right i know from oh not in in the
photos the
yeah no no no the king
is kind of like
he's he kind of betrayed sweden i mean
he's no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
no stop stop
he's putting in a good word for sweden
every time he talks about it
yeah that's true he's very he's very
free from controversy the swedes like
pewdiepie you love pewdiepie
and now again are you being ironic or
serious
serious this time okay the swedes are
proud of pewdiepie of course yeah this
is the biggest
yeah we love him yeah
do you watch him
yeah sure yeah
i can't tell if he's serious
i am serious i like pewdiepie okay good
yeah fantastic i do too by the way just
trying to understand
um
if pewdiepie led a mutiny in sweden who
would would people overthrow the king in
favor of pewdiepie
oh interesting
so yeah
probably interesting because you know
there's a lot of people that don't like
the king if i'm going to be honest
got it but but everyone's okay
and then we're coming down we've got
some kind of ikea flags some kebab
what's going on here
yeah so we got the ikea ikea is of
course another
we're very proud of that
ikea is
all over the world and it represents
sweden they they keep all the swedish
names and all like that so we love them
gotta represent them swedish flag oh and
we got we got a little stove for the
extra cabin cozy stuff yeah love that
what's this a photo of here
oh that's like a typical swedish cabin
this is beautiful this is the outside of
the
well if this was a house that would be
at our side basically and what's with
the kebab there you just yeah is that a
sweet this is
yeah this is a swedish kebab because in
sweden like many people don't know this
in sweden kebab is like the primary
thing we eat really no joke yeah i'm not
being ironic
is it
is it
is it's imported though right like
that's not a traditional
appropriation
no but well
in germany when i was there we were all
eating kebab too it was turkish food
though right that's what i was gonna say
is it it it's like imported from from
turkey or somewhere else in the middle
east is it not not the food itself he's
talking about like the the
the cuisine like sweden didn't yeah come
upon
their own right like they i think it's
like we eat mexican food here you know
that's what i mean
if i'm gonna speculate i'm guessing like
because we have a lot of immigration had
a lot of immigration i guess they
brought it
right okay
there's a kebab shop at every corner
literally everything i love that man
right when i wasn't when i was in
germany boy
the kebab was just i [ __ ] loved that
[ __ ] so good
in sweden we mix
like the kebab place with pizzeria so
it's like wow
and we have kebab pizza it's like the
biggest pizza in sweden oh my goodness
on a different level
and you know what the city i live in was
elected as the best kebab city in sweden
wow what an honor wow so we put a kebab
up he's right honor of your city i
googled swedish kebab and it's all
pictures of pizza oh would you look at
that yeah let me just get let me get a
look at that i'm hungry
oh he looks bad that does not look
terrible okay so this this is send us a
good one
yeah but basically it's just pizza with
kebab as topping
yeah and there's a special sauce that
only my city knows
nobody's unlocked the secrets i'm not
even kidding people all over sweden
travel here
uh to eat it
send me that send a picture i need to
see that yeah
i just googled my city and this
instantly came up
here it is you can have a kebab plate
that's also very fast here's the real
deal from love himself
on both screens
oh my goodness that's the real [ __ ]
we're hungry now what is this sauce
we're looking at
it's a special sauce no one knows what
it what's in it
it's like
is it yogurty is it ranchy what's going
on well it's creamy probably yogurt
based but um it doesn't taste yogurt is
there cheese on this pie
like under yeah it's a normal pizza okay
yeah with tomato and then you have kebab
and then the sauce is in the sauce wow
and it's getting hungry
thin pizza wait is that just tahini yeah
that's what i thought too maybe is that
just tahini it looks like tahini is that
just sesame seed oil mixed with water
he's like oh [ __ ] they know the
cigarettes and lemonade garlic
you know
it's not no garlic in yeah it's probably
garlic but
people
like try to recreate it and apparently
there's like
pineapple juice
jalapeno juice all this kind of weird
stuff yeah it's called bernays it's a
close cousin of mayo but with butter
it's delicious unfortunately in sweden a
lot of store-bought sauces label it as
bernay's sauce but it's just mayo with
some spices
which is what people usually put in
there
yeah love's right i i'm
looking around a little bit and um
yeah i've
here's a reddit post from a few years
ago with a bunch of people asking about
it and literally the top reply i've
asked kebab places around town but they
all just mumble something about it being
secret
[Laughter]
so wait i'm telling you
what is in jungkook
spice
we've reached peep kabad spice people
this is like a whole thing about this
kebab
sauce huh it's so good
this is a whole thing this plate here's
a review i found on tripadvisor where
we've reached peak kebab sauce four out
of five stars yeah what the [ __ ] was
that that sounds like a five star
why go here
now i'm just reading pizza reviews this
is good [ __ ] yeah
and we are
well they said they said the town
of hoke
has probably more pizzerias than
inhabitants
yeah wow
if you go do you want to go to google
maps and search pizzeria in german
shopping yeah it's gonna be like
everywhere
there's not 200 meters where there's not
a pizzeria
do you eat a lot of pizza
sure maybe once a week
at least that's always here's your town
yep
what do you think of that
this doesn't even show all when you zoom
in there's going to be like every on
every street wow
here let me zoom in close
yeah yeah
here
and go up a little bit
the main cit
the main the main street i don't know
okay there we go look at that nice and
you go to the left i could be happy in
your town dude oh it's
i'm moving to sweden man i didn't know
about all this uh kebab sauce i'm gonna
bring you guys some kebabs yeah you
bothered that [ __ ] you bring it here i
want some of that damn song yeah
yeah but you can't buy too much at the
same time because they're going to be
suspicious you need to buy i guess you
can ask for a big
like box of it but they won't give you
too much so you will
that's awesome come back so is do they
have like a they must have a secret
society where they share the recipe
yeah i mean it's super weird how the
culture is because
all the people i don't know if this
sounds bad but all the pizzerias are
like middle eastern owners yeah it's not
turkish
and they i guess they all like kind of
collaborate and they keep it secret yeah
but it's a swedish phenomenon which is
interesting are you sure it's not tahina
i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure because
they're middle eastern it looks like
tahina
now that they're i'm finding out their
middle eastern the herbs are like
cultures
pineapple juice i'm seeing lots of
discussion about pineapples
yeah i'm seeing lots of discussion about
how how it hit the sauce hits different
in sweden and it's a big mystery of of
what the recipe is so
if anybody out there knows
what you should start with we should
start pizzeria when you move here love
[ __ ] yeah let's do it
a swedish turkish pizzeria here in los
angeles
hi swedish friends a good friend of mine
came
he told me about swedish kebab sauce
i've had kebab sauce all over europe but
he explained the swedish kebab sauce
it's different very good and he says
it's not tzatziki sauce well and it's
not like other kebab sauces i'm trying
to find a recipe
the top comment is i've asked kebab
places around town but they all mumble
something about earlier oh you found the
same thread there's a lot of recipes out
there it's hard to pinpoint the kebab
sauce but i make mine with yogurt
mayo
chili sauce sambal and a bit of vinegar
and pressed garlic sounds good
sure
this person said it's just tahini so
it sounds like it's some kind of yogurt
based sauce
yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] hell dude you got me all right
it's great i'm going crazy for this damn
i'm hungry what are we doing for lunch
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
all right well love you
your toilet may be hungry whatever that
means
but we love it
thank you
seek it for life
a little feek on the toilet
all right finally mine
i don't know how this one's gonna play i
gave them a pretty insane pitch
so let's see
what came of it so my idea
was that
[Music]
it's like a space journey okay
and this this looks good so you've got a
lazy boy
right
you sit in the lazy boy
you recline
and then you got a tube to put your dick
in and pee or if you're a girl that
there's an attachment it kind of works
the same way you could make it happen i
think
now why the tube versus just using the
because you're reclining
um
i see so the angle would be yeah now
that that that makes sense yeah i
thought that was a catheter
sort of is it sort of how big's your
conch dude
[Laughter]
catheter
i'm sorry proceed is there like suction
on there yeah yeah okay it's got to suck
otherwise it just so it sucks your dick
it doesn't you have to be right you
think of it in a sexual way but yes it
sucks yeah it sucks your dick i doubt it
will do much for you it's just a tube
with suction
sure zach can get creative with this
sure and so are we all just sharing this
tube in the office
uh yes definitely i can't point it out
you were grossed out by the communal
bidet but the communal dick tube is
totally fine
yeah i mean you you give it a squirt of
a bleach or clorox or something yeah
you know that's that's sanitary
yeah so you you recline
you put the tube on your genitals
and it's a full relaxation
moment you what you're facing all walls
have a
kind of tv screens and once there's
sensors in the toilet
once the poop exits your butt you enter
warp speed
right okay
you're traveling at warp speed through
the stars this is during
the moment of pooping there's the the
moment of cresting the moment of
of
poop
coming out and things happening
at the moment you've dropped your last
log again the sensors in the toilet will
detect that
and this is when you drop out of
hyperspace
and you have to navigate
an asteroid field sick as you wipe
because you know metaphorically it's
kind of what you're going through is it
like a joystick on the armrest
to like how are you navigating with the
tube
oh
direction of the wiping
yeah it could be yeah there's like i
said there's sensors in the toilet
i see so the asteroids obviously
represent nugs that you're secure
avoiding or you're removing but yeah i
think it's based on the direction of the
wipe and the there's advanced sensors
toilet so you are you are
navigating this minefield
and as you finish
and your butt is clean you arrive to a
10 000
wookies celebrating your
your accomplishment
and that's when you come when you flush
no when you flush oh
no no no there's no coming this is
purely
this is not a sexual thing zach this was
very creative i'm very impressed
yeah i mean everyone's was creative
but i mean like imagine flushing the
toilet and seeing like a hundred wookies
going cheering yeah you know because you
know
i mean it's not that it's just star
tours [ __ ]
i'm just realizing
yeah it's just star tour [ __ ] it's true
it's dope
but it's an interactive experience i
like the interactivity i like that
there's positive reinforcement you know
you probably learned that while uh potty
training your son it definitely has a
lot to do with that right yeah i think
that's entered my mind quite a bit yeah
so this is it this is my dream
i love it i love it i think everybody
did a fantastic job i'd really be happy
with almost any of these you know and i
think every guy at one point their life
has thought about a pee dick tube
especially when you're in bed and you
just think god if i could only piss and
knock it out of bed if there was some
kind of tube you could pee in
um that would be a dream
yeah i always think about it on road
trips like dick tube dick too yeah lena
falls asleep
i'm sick of using vitamin you know water
bottles you do that
there's been times you don't just pull i
mean
do you do it in front of lena she's
knocked out she she doesn't know you
don't be in front of her no i'll be in
front of her i just won't piss in a
bottle in front of her that's what i
mean oh yeah you pissed in a bottle from
her and does she know though that you do
that no no no she's like oh she's super
clean she'd freak out yeah i had a
feeling that if because what do you do
with the bottle if you you got a bottle
of piss what do you do with that just
toss it out the window no i don't i
don't literally
i don't litter
it's sterile wait what do you do with
the bottle
you know i didn't think this line of
questioning would go this far you did
throw it out the window no i didn't bro
station you put it you wrap it up inside
uh a bag you have multiple what if she
wakes up before you get there
you just say don't don't go in the snack
bag bag
[ __ ] you threw it out the window why
would you want a [ __ ] jar full of
piss in your car
throw that [ __ ] thing out the water
you know it would be less embarrassing
to say just throughout the window when i
honestly didn't i throw it away at the
rest stop keeps it in the cupboard wait
has lina ever
she's never seen one of your piss
bottles
no the only one time i could think of
was we were crossing the border to
canada
and we were on the bridge and
i went in the back seat my sister has a
camaro it was my sister's car it was
just me lena though but it was in the
back seat and i pissed in a bottle
because i couldn't hold it
amen uh yeah and she didn't she knew she
found out she no she knew about that
time because she was driving you told
her it was happening she she was she was
there while it was happening yeah she
knew why was she freaking out she was
okay with it uh she was
she wasn't happy about it but she wasn't
like mean about it either the thing is
when i fight i'm afraid if i piss in a
bottle it'll be too much and it will
like because that's a bad situation when
you realize there's not enough volume
vitamin water actually yeah how much
well if you're talking about like a
standard like you know two
or two liters no no no it's like stan
not two liters that's too big whatever
the 20 ounce 20 ounce uh bottle yeah
arrowhead bottle yeah exactly that
that'd be a lot of piss still i think
you i think you're good i don't know
well the problem is i mean it'd be hard
to fit the tip in to that opening well
you don't put the hole not if you have a
small dick zach or that i'm just kidding
no you just put the [ __ ] hole in
there dude yeah but that that's a whole
other game in itself i mean like you
gotta you gotta get the aim right
i was just afraid of being stopped by
like the canadian uh border patrol and
like
them searching the car cause they do
that a lot when you caught across from
detroit
did you drip at all
i
i hope not my sister doesn't deserve
that
i don't recall though
there's an uh it's i mean let's be real
it's gonna happen at least a little bit
like splash
yeah that's a dangerous game yeah oh my
god i just peed in my basement well a
good one is a go as a gatorade bottle
you could stick the whole you could get
they got that big
jump down there yeah that's the way to
go brisk iced tea you know those brisk
big ass [ __ ] glass hole great [ __ ]
bottle right yeah
you'll want to be doing it with those
glass coke bottles though disgusting
though yeah
well there you have it
there you have it learned a lot about
everyone
so we're going to set up a poll
yep on friday we're going to vote for
who made the best bathroom and then we
should start the poll
now we should put in the description of
this episode
good idea and then we can keep
encouraging people on friday to go vote
in that same poll we'll announce the
winner on friday right yeah very
exciting
roll it
well um believe it or not we're pretty
much out of time that is unbelievable
we've been having way too much fun i
didn't get to bowling alley memes maybe
we can do this on friday because i love
this yeah yeah definitely we're gonna
have to
and drake at the strip club that was
such a good story
uh ela seemed pretty interested in that
story so maybe we can present it to her
we have so much stories left okay well
we're going to get out to this one
friday we'll have a great big show for
you guys on friday get back on the rails
ethan i'm um he's working i'm back on
the rails don't worry i mean technically
we do have a few minutes left but i
don't know if it's enough time to do it
it's actually later a [ __ ] it's five
o'clock [ __ ] is that real oh my god 4 45
yeah i got to wrap it up here
but we're gonna have a big old juicy
episode for you guys tomorrow
or well no not tomorrow on friday friday
it'll be tomorrow
right tomorrow when this episode goes
out
very confusing
all right well
thank you guys for watching thank you to
all of our members
people who become members get this
episode a day early
and you get access to exclusive content
bts behind the scenes one video a week
new bts is really good evie saying he's
hyped up about it when are you posting
that
uh
so
i'm done with it now but we're going
somewhere tomorrow night that i may want
to include in there i don't know if i
should spoil it but
oh yeah oh yeah you should include that
yeah that would be good yeah
fun great that's awesome thank you a.b
great job on that thank you lots of good
feedback on the last bts that was for
members only guys
okay well um
thank you guys it's been a joy it's been
a treat it's been a treasure lots of
highs lots of lows
john cena
[Music]
reshooting the beginning how long ago
was that that yeah that was a lifetime
ago
the rejection
it's all here
off the rails
number 19. beautiful stuff
god bless you
bye bye
[Music]